[Music]
Savior monster guardian vigilante of the
preservation of life so often the
justification for taking it
humans elevating those that keep guard
until they watch too close and the
so-called hero condoning the very act he
would condemn transgressions of the past
shape action to come
[Music]
at Ossining turn into a scary
yesterday's law
leads to madness
and God becomes silent becomes outcast
become diet as faction dissolves and for
and lust for power enslave all
such folly and if utility immigrant
design
how lines weren't clearly defined become
blurred
who
perhaps it is time for them to be
redrawn
you're going to spit up on the Atrocitus
you know who else does that babies you
will rule earth Grodd hey I have and
will again Atlantis
can't be my enemy next one try diplomacy
the kid that's why we're here
hey youtubers its charlie oh my god new
injustice to footage so let's break this
down in no face can this morning just
because I cut myself shaving but no
words I should be fine by the second
video today this is basically picking up
right where the story of the first game
left off Superman's followers trying to
free him like you see Damian Wayne going
against Batman - Batman versus Robin
battle lines being redrawn because
Brainiac is coming and then Darkseid is
floating on the horizon so because this
is so awesome and it's not dropping till
May I'm actually going to do an
injustice giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave an
injustice related comment on this video
the winners are announced at the end of
the video so be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so that you don't miss
anything
Brainiac is the main villain of this arc
of like the injustice - so he's
basically going to be coming mixing
things up at they also teased a couple
extra new characters like poison ivy
Robin in the big pre-order is Darkseid
so it's like oh you pay a little extra
right now you actually get Darkseid so
if you didn't play injustice 1 they sort
of tell you the story of that game over
the course of this trailer it starts
with the deaths of Superman's wife Lois
Lane his child it drives him mad it
creates this new regime where he's this
tyrant ruling over all so it's kind of
like a what-if evil Superman story so
while the heroes and the villains of
Earth are split so you have like Batman
here who is working with Harley Quinn
like brainiacs voice over in the trailer
Hiro's condoning the actions of people
that he would once condemn so it implies
that Batman who's been fighting against
Superman's regime Batman sort of leads
the other opposite side of things so you
see him working with a lot of his rogues
gallery Superman also working with a lot
of his rogues gallery - but the new
characters that are playable in this
game that were not playable before
include people like the reverse-flash
Damian Wayne that Robin
Supergirl Gorilla Grodd Harley Quinn
Power Girl Bane Atrocitus Deadshot
Darkseid Aquaman the John Stuart Green
Lantern and Brainiac will also have
downloadable content that will also
release more characters that way
obviously more skin but
you read the comic book story for the
first run for the first injustice game
they're going to do a digital comic book
for the second game so there will be
like another story that you can read but
you'll also get a lot of that through
the cutscenes in the game like this is
one of the big final cutscenes from the
first game
[Music]
with Superman's regime toppled new
governments formed to take its place
new governments meant new customers for
Deathstroke and business was booming
soon there were more assassinations to
carry out revolutions to aid and unrest
to create than he could manage on his
own the one earth regimes elite troopers
having committed atrocities and
Superman's name had gone into hiding
from a populace
bent on revenge impossible for those to
find but not for Deathstroke recruiting
these renegades he formed the new Titans
the world premiere political assassin so
a lot of that just depends on which
character you're playing which battles
you win he had slightly different
cutscenes based on who wins the matches
so mortal combat style they have
cutscenes that are just tailored to
whatever your narrative is in the game
but it looks badass let me know what you
guys think it doesn't drop til May 16th
so you have like plenty of time to
pre-order if you don't have enough money
right now so even though they're saying
the dark side is pre-order only you
might be able to get him down the road
via DLC it was a gameplay trailer that I
did earlier so I'll link to that at the
end of this but the story itself like
literally just picks up right where the
story of the first game leaves off with
AB Superman under lock and key
Batman's faction is trying to pick up
the pieces of society but the other
people of Superman's faction are trying
to free him to reinstate him then you
have Brainiac coming in and taking
advantage of all this chaos implying
that he is going to redraw the battle
line so all the teams the factions will
change completely by the end of this
story
I'm not Clark's enemy mister is a funny
way to show it you haven't heard the
whole story there will be a lot of fun
the story is really WTF like normally
like I wouldn't consider this a good
option for like a big movie I think it
works fine in the game it's just so
pessimistic because when you consider
that Superman killed his wife killed
Lois Lane in their unborn child
because he'd been given fear toxin from
the Joker laceless kryptonite it just
sounds like the most WTF setup ever so I
feel like it works really well in the
context of this game so I think that
works in this spin-off universe you have
to consider this is like a different
universe inside the multiverse but if
they were try to turn it into an actual
movie people are probably pretty upset
well let me know if you guys are most
hype about and I'll say congratulations
to the first injustice winner that's
easily be sure to private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there is a new
round that started in this video so what
I'll do is I'll alternate the injustice
giveaway with the flash ring giveaway
going forward because this is all DC so
I'll just say like which giveaway is
going on whenever I post new DC videos
so there's probably going to be some new
flash later tonight but if there any
injustice videos that you guys want me
to do in the meantime about explaining
the story just let me know in the
comments what you guys wait for that to
post the actor to play steady on the
flash tease these coming back you can
click here to learn all about that you
can click here to learn all about the
new x-men Legion TV show thank you so
much for watching everybody
what's that five I'll see you guys
tonight